[Música]
el commit 19 nos ha obligado a una
cultura en casa aunque hay un antídoto
que lo resiste y es la danza si hoy sin
contacto y sin actuación plena pero como
dice el principal bailarín del stuttgart
ballet en su fecha mundial exhibe su
esencia jamás en la historia reciente a
la comunidad dancística si había visto
desafiada de tal forma para permanecer
motivada y encontrar su razón de ser los
bailarines son reconocidos por su
destreza física cuando en realidad no
sostenemos más por nuestra fuerza mental
creo que es esta combinación única de
agilidad de lo físico y lo psicológico
lo que nos ayudará a sobreponernos a
reinventarnos para seguir bailando e
inspirando en la vida el francés
jean-jacques nueva parte del ballet
moderno hubiera pensado que su natalicio
en el siglo 18 serviría de efeméride al
movimiento y menos que el tango pudiera
ser acuático porque es así como la
bailarina española ariadna jefes han
logrado fusionar sus sueños de criatura
marina con 600 de inmersiones en 5 días
sólo para el vídeo el agua fuerza tener
el ritmo en la mente a gestos más lentos
pero es una ausencia
que el rigor clásico desaparece dando
paso a la libertad
[Música]
claro que la tierra es el punto natural
de la danza hecha arte en este tema de
aceptación al dolor y feminidad de
ximena sariñana con pasos del mexicano
diego vega
[Música]
cabello
si bien los reyes de las coreografías
son los productores británicos jungle
quienes siempre elevan con baile su
viaje sonoro que tendrá tercer disco en
agosto y arranca diciéndonos que móvil
sigamos moviéndonos
[Música]
en el año del 60 aniversario del estreno
fílmico the west side story que tendrá
versión de steven spielberg algo de
bailarines enfrentados tiene el clip day
and girls sin embargo ahora son sus 10
oscar lo que nos interesan para sellar
el capítulo de los premios en su primera
nominación amanda seyfried no tuvo
fortuna siendo la estrella marion babies
de la hollywoodense mex pero es a rodaje
que fue como una clase de cine se palpa
en su rol en things heart en sin el
suspenso está servido en el marco de una
casa con un historial de asesinatos lo
enigmático es porque su pareja un
profesor con quien tiene un hijo y
acepta seguirlo en su nuevo puesto le
oculta que la casa en la ciudad de shows
en tiene una historia ante la
deshonestidad es el mundo de espíritus
le dará cierto consuelo a su personaje
en la otra caracoles de unión
estadounidense franco-británicas y tuvo
estatuilla al corto documental hoy no
sólo lo tratamos porque el diario the
gardian como productor lo haya subido a
youtube sino porque ahí el horror si es
real a la vez que conmovedor imaginen
haberse prometido que en la vida pondría
en un pie la alemania o más exacto en el
campo de concentración de mittelbau dora
que les arrebató a un hermano eso se
decía la nonagenaria francesa colette
magán catering hasta que el estudiante
luisín de 17 años la convence a ese
viaje me dio tributo me dio impacto
doloroso mostraba con nobleza
pues a ser también online vibrante es la
cita que les sugerimos con el pintor y
teórico ruso del arte abstracto vasily
kandinsky fallecido en francia en 1944
hasta apenas 12 años que sus obras
fueron pasión retrospectiva en el centro
pompidou de parís hoy por la pandemia
una de las más icónicas está a un clic
siendo además una sinfonía amarillo rojo
y azul
vasily kandinsky usó sólo estos tres
colores para crear en 1925 y con el
mismo título este vibrante trabajo es lo
que significaba la pintura resultado de
20 años de investigación sobre la
relación entre color y sentimientos a la
izquierda esta soleada y luminosa área
representa calidez a la derecha
encontramos colores más sombríos y fríos
mientras que muchos ven un paso entre el
día y la noche en el crepúsculo rojo del
centro el artista ruso empleó este
espectro de colores para ilustrar su
carrera en 1925 formó parte de la
escuela alemana bauhaus un movimiento
caracterizado por un estilo simple y de
líneas rectas pero la bauhaus perseguida
por los nazis se mudó a eeuu y kandinsky
no sólo dejó atrás clases y fiestas sino
que de ángulos pasó a un estilo más
personal con un redescubrimiento por las
curvas aunque el pintor siempre creció
en nuestra libertad para interpretar su
trabajo de la misma manera que
apreciamos una melodía
la música fue una referencia importante
para kandinsky él usaba términos
musicales para nombrar algunas de sus
pinturas llamó algunas improvisaciones y
a otras composiciones nombres de la
cultura musical
musical kandinsky solía imaginar varios
sonidos mientras movía sus pinceles hoy
en el centro de pompidou y google arts
intentan imaginar aquello que
acompañarían a amarillo rojo y azul
[Música]
una experiencia sensorial para ver y oír
al igual que kandinsky
y esta semana la música trae buenas
nuevas ya que el concierto experimental
de love of lesbian en españa' ha probado
que si bien requieren mascarillas ips
eventos masivos así podrían ser no super
transmisores del virus con sólo seis
casos de 4.592 asistentes hay dudas
sobre la vigencia de las pruebas y sobre
quién cargaría con ellas pero hay
esperanza
la esperanza de poder gozar en vivo del
nuevo álbum de zahara solo con mary
chanes supimos que sería uno de los
trabajos del año
confesando historias propias de dolor y
culpa universales pero ese incómodo
del título nos pone en esa piel que se
expida abrazando mujeres como taylor
swift o dolores y ahí llega la libertad
de bailar como si aún fuera real
cuídense y hasta la próxima gracias y me
despido trucos
[Música]